my name is Donald Hicks I currently lead
the global support operations team here
at Twitter my whole professional journey
has been one that's been unpredictable
and exciting I would love to tell you
the journey going from hardware to
software and platform support was one
that was really well thought out and it
was calculated it actually wasn't
leaning on the work and the experiences
I got out of SCP I felt like I was
better able to show up and a more
positive way when I joined here and more
important that was just more confident
in it heck it was okay not to know and
to fail fast and these are all the ideas
that they reinforced with any program
prior to SCP you could best describe me
as a hard-working mercenary
take-no-prisoners focused primarily on
ascending in my career when I was a part
of SCP you get the opportunity to refine
your academic sort of understanding of
key terms and frameworks you get an
opportunity to be introduced to new
approaches like negotiation SCP gave me
the license the permission to take
appalls
and really learn about me and sort of
rediscover what makes me whole and when
you take that moment it evokes a lot of
different emotions nervousness fear
excitement it reminded me of how closed
off I really was as a leader and what
was really refreshing was understanding
that I was not alone in my emotions and
that a lot of my classmates whether they
had different roles or jobs as me all
walked around in their profession with
the same set of emotions the feeling of
isolation since the program I have
evolved as a leader and hopefully as a
better leader it's okay to make mistakes
learn fast for some of your failures in
experiment again coming out of the
program I was able to make a huge pivot
toward choosing a job that helped me
make an impact in the world